IT TURNS OUT THAT JOURNALISTS
HAVE SWITCHED TEAMS.
THEY ARE WITH THE POWERFUL NOW.
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO SHUT THE
HELL UP.
THIS CONGRESSMAN REPRESENTS
NEVADA.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE READ THIS
MEMO.
IT SURE IS THAT IT IS NOT BEING
OVERSOLD.
YOU THINK THIS MEMO WILL CHANGE
AMERICAN CITIZENS?
>> TWO THINGS THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS SHOULD EVALUATE WHEN
THEY READ THIS PETER GOT TO
EVALUATE THE MEMO IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE FIVE MONTHS OF MISSING
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND HIS MISTRESS LISA
PAGE.
THEY HAVE TO BE EVALUATED
TOGETHER.
THERE.
HOW ARE THOSE CONNECTED EXACTLY?
>> TUCKER, I CAN'T GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS PRECISELY, I CAN ONLY
SAY THAT I DON'T THINK IT IS AN
ACCIDENT THAT STRZOK AND PAIGE,
WHO WERE VOLLEYING TEXTS BACK
MORE THAN A HIGH SCHOOL
VOLLEYBALL SQUAD, SUDDENLY HAD
THAT MORE THAN -- A CONSPIRACY
TO UNDERMINE THE PRESIDENT
ENDING IN THE APPOINTMENT OF
ROBERT MUELLER CONSPICUOUSLY THE
VERY DAY THAT THE STRZOK AND
PAGE TEXT MESSAGES COME BACK
ONLINE.
NO COINCIDENCE.
THE SECOND THING YOU GOT TO
EVALUATE IS THE MANNER IN WHICH
EVIDENCE PRESENTED TO THE COURT
WAS CORROBORATED.
THE PROBLEM WITH LIES IS THEY'VE
GOT TO KEEP TELLING THEM.
YOU CAN JUST TELL ONE LIVE.
YOU HAVE TO USE OTHER LIES TO
COOPERATE.
IT IS MY POSITION THAT THE
MUELLER PROBE IS -- THAT IT
SHOULD END IMMEDIATELY SO WE CAN
FOCUS ON THE REAL CHALLENGE OF
REFORMING THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ABOUT THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN UNDER A
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: THAT IS RIGHT, IT
IS A BIPARTISAN CONCERN.
WHAT YOU ARE SUGGESTING IS
CORRUPTION SO DEEP AND MENACING
THAT EVERY AMERICAN OUGHT TO BE
REALLY UPSET ABOUT IT.
CAN YOU PLEDGE, AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, THAT YOU WILL DO
EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO EXPOSE
THIS AND LET PEOPLE MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER IT
IS APPALLING OR NOT?
BUT DON'T YOU THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR CITIZENS TO
HAVE FAITH IN THEIR GOVERNMENT
AND, IN ORDER TO HAVE THAT
FAITH, THEY NEED MORE
INFORMATION SOON?
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
THINK YOU SOLVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS BY HAVING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS MEET WITH EACH OTHER
ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF GOVERNMENT WE
HAVE, WHAT TYPE OF INFORMATION
WE WILL HAVE BEFORE PEOPLE'S
LIBERTY IS IMPAIRED.
I THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION TO HAVE, AND I THINK
THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO GET
THERE IS BY RELEASING THIS MEMO.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, DEVIN NUNES
THAT.
I HAVE A HARD TIME KEEPING TRACK
OF WHERE THEY ARE.
THEN THEY NOW APPARENTLY HAVE
THEIR OWN MEMO WHICH IS JUST A
LUDICROUS PROPOSITION.
>> Tucker: IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING.
WE CAN SUCCESSFULLY GET ANY
DEMOCRAT ON THE SHOW TO EXPLAIN.
THE ARGUMENT BEHIND RELEASING
IT.
MY MISTAKE AND REMEMBERING THAT
THE FISA LAW WAS JUST RELEASED?
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN HELPFUL TO
HAVE THIS BEFORE THAT HAPPENED?
>> WOULD HAVE PREFERRED THAT, IT
IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
REAUTHORIZATION OF FIGHTS WAS
NOT A BLANKET REAUTHORIZATION.
WERE INCLUDED.
THAT WAS THE SECTION OF FISA
THAT DEALS WITH OVERSEAS
COLLECTION OF INTELLIGENCE AND
WILL
WILL RELEASE THE MEMO WE WILL
SEE HOW THAT INTERACTS OR MAYBE
HE DOESN'T INTERACT.
CAN'T CONFIRM OR DENY THOSE
DETAILS.
SPEND THE REST OF US ARE GETTING
REALLY ANXIOUS, NOT BECAUSE OF
PARTISAN REASONS, BUT BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO TRUST THAT YOUR
GOVERNMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AREN'T BEING USED FOR
POLITICAL REASONS, IT IS SIMPLE
AND IMPORTANT.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO SEE THE
MEMO?
>> I THINK WE WILL SEE IT WITHIN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS, NOW
DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING A CLAIM
THAT THE MEMO IS CONCLUSORY.
I THINK CHAIRMAN NUNES IS
BREAKER.
WHAT SUPPORTING INFORMATION CAN
THAT ALLOWS US TO HAVE A MORE
ROBUST FACT-BASED DISCUSSION
RATHER THAN JUST LOBBING
RELEASED YET.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE ARE RIGHTFULLY GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO THAT WE
DON'T DISCLOSE SOURCES AND
METHODS OR PUT AMERICANS WHO ARE
DOWNRANGE IN ANY JEOPARDY BUT
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY EXPOSE WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A DEEP-SEATED
CORRUPTION THAT HAS REALLY
UNDERMINED THIS PRESIDENCY,
THE INTEL COMMUNITY SPECIALIZES